hacemos
[Música]
hoy les voy a enseñar cómo hacerse un
autoexamen así fue como encontré mi
cáncer empecemos a través de sus cuentas
de instagram y 'tik tok' la francesa
cintia acá se propuso a crear conciencia
sobre el cáncer de seno cintia habla sin
tabúes de su experiencia con esta
enfermedad de la cual se recuperó desde
octubre rosa el mes dedicado a crear
conciencia sobre el cáncer de mama da
consejos sobre cómo prevenir el cáncer y
también ayuda a las personas enfermas a
afrontarlo
soy cynthia tengo 36 años vivo en parís
y me diagnosticaron un cáncer de mama a
los 31 años
porque tuve cáncer de mama tan joven
la gente no se va a interesar por un
tema tan importante o tan serio como el
cáncer de mama si se trata de forma
demasiado seria
le dije voy a hablar del tema de manera
que la gente pueda relacionarse con él
que no se aburra y con humor
con los tres dedos de la mano usando la
yema de los dedos el brazo al lado van a
empezar a hacer círculos de fuera hacia
adentro moviendo los dedos alrededor del
pecho hasta llegar al pezón cuando
lleguen al pezón lo pueden presionar
para ver si hay alguna secreción como si
se sabe que el 85% de los cánceres de
mama son causados por disfrutones
endocrinos así que para mí la prevención
debe centrarse en qué cosas podemos
hacer para reducirlos
[Música]
ser hombre es hablar del alcohol que es
una de las causas del cáncer de mama que
no se menciona en absoluto
es hablar sobre el bienestar el estrés
la salud mental cosas así eso es algo
que también trae a la cuenta a otras
personas que no tienen cáncer de mama
como contarle a tu cita que no tienes un
seno la vida sexual después del cáncer
de mama es algo que realmente no existe
en la atención médica todos los
comentarios que he recibido han sido
super positivos y me hacen más preguntas
sobre cómo afronte el cáncer y cómo lo
descubrí que sobre el seno encima
para mí compartir mi experiencia no solo
fue una forma terapéutica de decir lo
supere
sino que también pensé que ayudaría a
otras personas que se sienten invisibles
[Música]
así que deben saber que es normal tener
miedo sentirse herido en su cuerpo y en
su feminidad
[Música]
tengo tres consejos que dar escuchen a
su cuerpo siempre traten de reducir al
máximo su exposición a los disruptores
endócrinos y sobre todo si sienten que
hay algo mal confíen en ustedes y vayan
al médico
y estas larvas que se mueven son larvas
de la mosca soldado negra criada en
bukavu en el oriente de la república
democrática del congo estas moscas
tienen una particularidad se alimentan
de restos de comida y pueden servir de
alimento a los animales de granja esta
es una solución ecológica y económica y
nuestro observador se embarcó en este
tipo de crianza
en el que equivocamos moscas soldado
negras estas moscas no pican y no comen
sólo toman agua y ponen huevos
recogemos estos huevos hasta que
eclosionen luego obtenemos en larvas que
alimentamos con los residuos recogidos
y al cabo de dos semanas tenemos alarmas
a grandes muy ricas en proteínas con las
que se alimentan ser dos veces y
gallinas
vendemos nuestras proteínas a los
agricultores locales antes todos los
agricultores tenían que cruzar la
frontera con ruanda burundi y uganda
para comprar la proteína los
agricultores solían comprar un kilo por
dólar nosotros lo vendemos 0.75 dólares
y lo que producimos aquí anima a los
agricultores a involucrarse más porque
ahora tienen acceso a alimentos más
baratos para sus animales
es la población del áfrica subsahariana
no deja de crecer y según la onu los
insectos como fuente de proteína son un
futuro recurso para garantizar la
seguridad alimentaria porque los
insectos están en todas partes se
reproducen rápidamente son ricos en
nutrientes y su producción tiene un bajo
impacto ambiental en comparación con las
proteínas vegetales
para cultivar soya hay que destruir los
bosques y saltear el ecosistema pero
cuando se cree insectos ni siquiera se
necesita electricidad para convertir los
residuos en proteínas además los
residuos que recogemos contaminan el
medio ambiente y vamos a recoger todos
estos residuos es cierto
si limpiamos el entorno para producir
proteínas para ayudar a combatir la
inseguridad alimentaria que sufre el
país
es todo por esta semana en los
observadores de france 24 si usted
quiere comunicarse con la producción del
programa nuestros datos de contacto
aparecen en sus pantallas esperamos sus
historias también sus fotografías y
videos nos vemos la próxima semana hasta
pronto